[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
d'associations avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Karine Darmon
fondatrice de Tema création qui organise
le Versailles des créateurs le 13 mai
prochain bonjour bonjour alors le 13 mai
prochain donc vous organisez le
Versailles des créateurs à la place du
marché Notre-Dame on va revenir sur cet
événement dans quelques instants que
vous organisez vous êtes au nom de votre
entreprise organisateur de l'événement
qu'est-ce que Thema création c'est une
nous faisons du loisir créatif sur
Versailles en accueille des
anniversaires des ateliers créatifs pour
des enfants d'une tranche d'âge allant
de 6 à 13 14 ans ça dérange que les ados
changent beaucoup mais on avait des
adultes au jus avant jusqu'au covid et
puis aujourd'hui voilà les anniversaires
les ateliers enfants suffisent à
facombre le tout tous les créneaux donc
aujourd'hui nous voilà nous animons des
anniversaires thématiques alors exotique
sont constitué un projet à leur image
avec leur créativité qui est la leur ils
ont tous la même chose ils repartent
jamais avec la même chose et voilà c'est
un moment en convivial de partage et qui
permet de s'évader de ses écrans alors
au-delà d'organiser le verset des
créateurs vous allez également exposer
vos créations oui nous réalisons des
cartes artisanales intégralement faites
mains conçus dans notre atelier je les
créne ou les duplicons en petites séries
pour tout événement alors Noël
évidemment est une période phare pour
nous puisque on y écrit on envoie des
vœux mais il y a également des
événements familiaux des fêtes de foie
des anniversaires
etc et aujourd'hui ben voilà ou plutôt
qu'un mail on essaye de revaloriser un
peu l'image de la carte à envoyer qui
fait plaisir à ses aînés mais aussi à
ses cousins à sa famille voilà et ce
sont la carte la carte se perd justement
vous aviez déjà organisé les quatre de
2022 du Versailles il est créateurs pour
2023 trois éditions sont prévues la
première sera donc ce 13 mai pendant la
fête des mères quelle est l'histoire du
Versailles des créateurs et surtout
quels sont ses objectifs c'est un
élément qui existait de depuis quelques
temps à Versailles et l'année dernière
la mairie a fait un appel d'offres
puisqu'elle change d'organisateur
régulièrement ou demande un appel
d'offres on l'a vu un soir de février
assez pluvieux et avec mon conjoint on
s'est lancé dans l'aventure on a eu ces
quatre dates et on a rassemblé ben voilà
c'est devenu un des plus grands
événement de créateurs importants de
l'Ouest parisien et nous avons pu ouvrir
un au plus grand nombre de créateurs qui
ont des talents qui ont connu le covid
et qui aujourd'hui peuvent aller à
Versailles présenter leurs talents c'est
un événement important pour valoriser
justement le travail de ces créateurs
oui parce que c'est souvent des petites
activités ça se fait parfois en
parallèle d'une autre activité il y a
vraiment des mer moi je j'en connais ça
pour être moi-même créatrice et naviguer
un petit peu dans dans un microcosme
mais j'ai découvert des merveilles
franchement des merveilles des créateurs
qui sont qui sont vraiment passionnés
qui font encore une fois parfois ça en
parallèle d'une activité professionnelle
et qui ont un Talence ou en couture soit
dans le domaine du bijou soit le temps
de la céramique soit
enfin on y reviendra puisque ce sont
toutes les disciplines que vous allez
retrouver mais c'est impressionnant
parce que ce que les gens ont du talent
justement sans y exposants sont attendus
pour pour cette nouvelle édition quels
sont les domaines justement qui seront
représentants représentés par donc de
quelle exposant parle-t-on alors j'en ai
cité quelques-uns le bijou reste quand
même une activité très phare dans le
domaine de la création il y a la
maroquinerie il y a de la mode des
accessoires textiles couture il y a des
arts de la table il y a beaucoup de
céramiques il y a des céramises mais qui
ont encore une fois des talents
complètement différents c'est à dire que
dans un domaine de création on ne va pas
prendre des des choses similaires il
faut que chacun se distingue par une une
particularité une couleur certains sont
plus portés sur des couleurs sombres
mais sur des formes je pense à la
céramique certains c'est la même chose
pour les bijoux
il y a différents bijoux dans différents
avec des matériaux plus ou moins nobles
mais qui répondent et on y viendra à la
question de tous les budgets et en
céramique donc art de la table je vous
disais textile il y a des créatrices de
mode également il y a des produits de
cosmétiques et de bien-être
et on fait beaucoup de choses dans le
domaine du savon artisanal par exemple
savonnerie est un une création enfin un
monde de créateurs en qui monte
nous avons également des luminaires
alors
on a eu on a eu l'année dernière classic
vintage qui faisait des luminaires avec
des des
[Musique]
barils des sens ah ok ouais on a
mais en plus la création c'est ce qu'on
peut défendre à travers cet événement
c'est que la création s'est avant tout
de l'art on va chez un artisan chez un
créateur mais qui nous fait à la fois
découvrir de l'art mais en même temps sa
création qu'on peut acheter qu'on peut
avoir chez nous en fait il y a un
créateur on va voir on va chercher un
savoir-faire qu'on ne trouve pas dans le
monde quand un produit est décliné de
manière industrielle on va chercher des
petites séries parfois du sur mesure
souvent des pièces uniques parce que on
crée quelque chose même nous dans le
domaine de la carterie je n'ai pas une
carte qui se ressemble même si ce sont
les mêmes il a toujours quelque chose
qui va se distinguer de différents donc
on va chercher des petites on va
chercher un savoir-faire on va chercher
de la passion parfois les gens
regrettent que ce soit parfois cher par
rapport à des produits industriels mais
ce ne sont pas des chaînes de
fabrication ce sont des heures et des
heures de travail quelques que l'on
quantifie jamais un créateur quantifiera
rarement ses heures de travail auquel
cas une vendrait jamais alors au-delà de
valoriser justement ce savoir-faire
artisanal local vous souhaitez également
que les exposants s'inscrivent dans une
démarche éco-responsable qu'est ce que
ça signifie alors pour certains ils
utilisent des matériaux notamment dans
le textile des produits qui répondent à
des normes donc écologique
il y a beaucoup de choses qui sont
faites alors dans le domaine du bijou on
va nous dire du métal c'est un peu
compliqué ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on
aimerait on aime les circuits courts
ceux qui vont acheter leur matériaux et
je connais des créatrices textiles qui
vont acheter en local dans les merceries
à Versailles par exemple
ensuite on est très regardant aussi sur
la provenance des produits on exclut
d'EM tous les produits qui sont
fabriqués à l'étranger ça c'est sûr
alors certains prennent des techniques
empreintes des techniques qui sont
réalisées par des artisans je pense
indiens sur une technique d'impression
on peut pas leur en vouloir mais tout ce
qui est fabriqué à l'étranger est exclu
vous comprendrez pourquoi pour le
circuit court de même que les
correspondabilités s'exercent aussi sur
la provenance des créateurs c'est la
raison pour laquelle on ne rayonne pas à
travers la France parce que ben voilà il
est en train de carbone on essaye de
trouver et puis il y a des talents
suffisamment proches
de Versailles et alentours commerce à
grands parcs Yvelines et départements
alentours pour trouver et trouver
suffisamment de créateurs dans divers et
différents domaines alors justement
qu'elle est à peu près le pourcentage
d'exposants qui viennent de des Yvelines
et quel est le pourcentage de des
exposants qui viennent des départements
limitrophes plus de la moitié reviennent
des Yvelines
et encore il y a des talents cachés
qu'on n'a pas encore trouvé mais on
s'exerce à le faire
et en fait on a pris les départements
limitrophes il est vrai qu'à Versailles
la proximité des débarquements des
Hauts-de-Seine et de l'Essonne n'est pas
si loin donc à la rigueur on joue à
domicile presque en venant de des
Hauts-de-Seine et puis il y a donc qui
draine avec eux aussi une
il y a aussi un aspect touristique
évidemment qui permet de faire venir des
elles font venir leur clientèle avec
elle alors souvent ça cet événement
prend aussi un aspect très familial et
très touristique des familles de Paris
sont venus passer la journée on
déjeunit sur place et on découvert
Versailles ou on présentait leurs
enfants le fameux château et j'insiste
justement sur le fait que donc
Versailles des créateurs c'est le 13 mai
et qu'il y en aura pour tous les goûts
et tous les budgets merci beaucoup
Karine Darmont d'avoir été avec nous sur
sensation pour plus d'informations on
peut se rendre sur le facebook ou le
Instagram le Versailles des créateurs
2023 et pour revoir au réécouter cette
émission rendez-vous sur notre site et
notre application radio sensation
[Musique]